j'aime bien les fêtes tu viens me lit
qu'arrivera-t-il sais tu m'oublies
quelques robes état je ne t'oublierai
jamais oui c'est promis même quand
j'aurai s'entend nous allons devoir
travailler ce week end jean christophe
mais j'ai promis à ma femme et à ma
fille de les emmener en week end
on aura besoin de tout ne vient pas à la
campagne c'est impossible
tu n'as qu'une seule vie ne passez pas à
côté
à faire que faire que faire en effet
mais oui ni jean christophe non l'arbre
de mon enfance était dans la forêt pas
ici à londres
il n'y a pas d'entrée j'imagine qu'il
est là où il doit être
ce que tu dis farfelu au mercy winnie
pourquoi es tu là alors c'est vrai il
faut que tu m'aides j'ai perdu tous mes
amis bons tirs ont ça au clair
attention unis me voilà il semblerait
que je sois coincé tu viens de manger du
miel ce n'est pas qu'une question
viennent pas aux allées j'arrive
toujours là où je vais en m'éloignant
d'où j'étais vraiment c'est comme ça que
je fais un jour briguer show christophe
tu reviens jouer avec un ami
essayons de retrouver par signer je suis
ici depuis déjà trop longtemps bonjour
tout le monde
quelle joie de vous revoir au mercy coop
et adour son jules tort pour mon travail
j'ai eu tort pour tous et je dois
rejoindre ma famille revoir jean
christophe au j'aurais aimé qu'il reste
un peu plus longtemps
c'est peut-être à notre tour de le
sauver
tu dois être mariani tué le petit tour
de dessins de mon père oui tu sais où il
est j'aime ce secteur hull c'est l'heure
de bondy j'ai le plus pitoyable
désinvolture d'identité juste devant moi
ok
porcine et si quelqu'un veut applaudir
c'est le moment ou jamais
mais jamais été joyeux en dit que rien
n'est impossible mais je fais rien tous
les jours
non c'est pas juste c'est pas grave
[Musique]